économie environnement énergie au social
il est
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
bonjour je m'appelle benoît je suis éco
délégués au collège en d'asthme je vais
vous présenter un éco gestes qui permet
d'économiser l'eau à la cantine à la fin
des repas nous récupérons l'eau d'hébron
pour arroser les plantes
pour réaliser votre système goutte à
goutte il vous faut une bouteille percer
des trous à l'arrière de votre bouteille
pour créer un appel d'air il vous faut
aussi un distributeur d'eau ou routaboul
on peut fabriquer le système goutte à
goutte en personne un bouchon mais le
problème c'est que l'eau c'est qu'on
très rapidement nous avons opté pour un
système en terre cuite achetés dans le
commerce l'eau s'écoule très lentement
par les tout petits ports de la terre
cuite avec une bouteille d'un litre 25
votre plante est arrosée pendant une
semaine
pour installer votre bouteille
d'arrosage et il vous suffit de la
remplir d'eau puis de la plante est à la
base de la plante il ne vous reste plus
qu'à la surveiller et à la remplir en
terrine
économiser jusqu'à 130 euros sur les
factures d'eau comment je prends une
douche plutôt qu'un bain j'ai fermement
robinet temps de me laver les mains les
dents ou en me rasant je n'utilise le
lave vaisselle et le lave linge que
s'ils sont pleins je choisis une chose
dont économique je récupère les eaux de
pluie pour effectuer des tâches comme le
nettoyage ou l'arrosage du jardin
j'arrose le jardin pendant les heures
les plus fraîches de la journée c'est à
dire tous le matin ou à la tombée de la
nuit je lave mon véhicule une fois par
mois à la maison ou dans une station
service et non dans la ravine alors vous
voyez préserver l'environnement c'est
augmenter votre pouvoir d'achat
le conseil général agit pour le
développement durable et vous
économie environnement énergie au social
il
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant